now to a remarkable development after a
cyber attack that crippled one of the
country's biggest gas lines
and led to fuel shortages and panic
buying by the drivers
the fbi has now recovered 2.3 million
dollars of the ransom pay to the hackers
in the form of the digital currency
known as bitcoin that's out of 4.3
million dollars
although the cryptocurrency's value does
fluctuate jeff begays is following this
at the justice department jeff
this does seem this kind of success does
seem very unusual and very rare
well it is a win for the department of
justice which just last week announced
that it would be treating these
ransomware cases like they do terrorism
cases here and this announcement
yesterday is perhaps proof
that this new change in approach is
paying off
the old adage follow the money still
applies
follow the money is exactly what the fbi
did last month when colonial pipeline
paid about 4.3 million dollars worth of
bitcoin
to russian hacking group darkside after
its malware was used to hold the company
hostage
the sophisticated use of technology to
hold businesses
and even whole cities hostage for profit
is decidedly a 21st century
challenge newly released court documents
show that investigators use
digital fingerprints to track those
funds to an online wallet for darkseid
the fbi then obtained the wallet's
private key to recover about 2.3 million
dollars
the extortionists will never see this
money
around 2 million dollars of the money
paid has yet to be recovered
and the bureau is still investigating
more than 100 types of ransomware
including last week's hack that stalled
operations for meat distributor jbs
as president biden's administration
looks at how to respond to cyber
criminals energy secretary jennifer
granholm
said this week on meet the press that
she supports
banning companies from paying hackers
paying of ransomware only
exacerbates and accelerates this problem
you are encouraging
the bad actors when that happens despite
this week's success
recovery may not be possible for all
paid ransoms
we cannot guarantee and we may not be
able to
do this in every instance
today colonial pipeline ceo he's going
to be on capitol hill
answering some tough questions from
lawmakers in fact they'll want to know
why the company paid the ransom in the
first place in the meantime president
biden meets with
vladimir putin next week during the
summit
in which the president will have really
tough questions for vladimir putin
because a lot of these
hackers are linked to russia
anthony jeff begays thank you jeff